I think that I really feel blessed to be
in this in this business it's I think
the thing that excited my dad the most
about it that he imparted to me was that
we're storytellers
were part of we're in the business of
communication and and that's what I love
about it and when it comes time for the
work I mean this first of all this is
something that's been there since the
beginning of time when they had the
campfire and the people are getting
around they have a story to tell and
they're telling about what's going on
and then village next but when it comes
time for the work for me it's it it's
there's a real spiritual side to it you
know after you prepare you do your
homework you all of that stuff and
you're in there with the other person
but then I just try to let it come
through me you know let the spirit come
and because acting is you know yes it's
entertaining people but it's it's
inviting people you know and it's best
it's inviting people on a spiritual
journey and informing us all about
something that is important whatever it
whatever that story happens to be and so
you need to just kind of release and
it's a good feeling because then you
don't feel that you have to do it I'll
generate it all from yourself it's
coming from a place that is unknown to
almost you know it's the spirit you know
the spirit of of telling the stories the
spirit of communicating the spirit of
loving your fellow man
yeah I agree with that I have a lot of
that going on with me in choosing a role
you know it's the story the people
you're getting to work with that sort of
thing but really I haven't we r de weird
method the fact that I've been so lucky
really affords me to have this you know
method but I really try not to work at
all try to you're not engaged you know I
really don't want anything anymore work
did I try to push it away and then when
it's too cool
you know when the story is just too good
or the the the people I'm working with
or to just too wonderful or or often you
know the the that spirit thing you take
the challenge you know it's funny like a
script like crazy heart when that first
came around for me I read it and said oh
man this is a you know about a musician
that could be cool you know and then I
found out that there was no music to the
thing that was a close one
it almost got way back and then I ran
into t-bone Burnett my buddy you know
we've known each other for a long time
and he said what do you think about this
crazy hard scripts and I said well why
are you asking me are you interested and
he said well I'll do it if you'll do it
I said really I said there's no music he
said I'll take care of that don't worry
about it
and so I said okay and now I was scared
shitless man because here I was very
safe in the dream world you know and now
I had to say it was a challenge you know
I had to bring that dream into reality
and I could fail you know I could fail
at something that I really didn't want
to fail at you know it's like I keep
getting that picture of the wide
receiver going out for that long ball
you know and
you know the championship game and
here's the perfect pass and you'd say
please catch it catch the ball you know
and so I you know that was one that was
just you know the challenge was too good
you know I kind of wet I made a painting
of a dream I had that really sums it up
for me
the dream is I'm going down a river you
know Robo and it's got cliffs on either
sides quite a wide river I guess it
could be about as wide as this room and
they're whirlpools all through the the
river and my task is to get through
those whirlpools and at the vortex of
each whirlpool is a beautiful jewel and
I find myself young in my dream I'm you
know growing like this and I see oh look
at that beautiful jewel oh look at that
and it's too late you know I'm suck
their and my oars are up like that and
that's my painting
that's the painting and the title of the
painting is Jeff makes a decision that's
my process that's basically my process